This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Once spring afternoon in 2011, Jeremy Clifton was in a rush. He was living in Atlanta trying to make ends meet, working as a tutor, a guitar teacher, and fitness instructor. On that day, he was running late to one of his many gigs. But as he waited for a train on the subway platform... I just heard a scream, and I looked down to my left and there was a guy down on the tracks.
And so I ran to him and I was about to reach him until someone yelled to me, don't touch him, don't touch him, don't touch him. Because he was right next to the third rail. The third rail, of course, is the live rail. It's surging with enough electricity to kill someone who touches it. In fact, first responders are taught to never grab someone who is in contact with the third rail because they could get electrocuted too.
I was like just six feet above him and trying to get him in a move and he began to come to and he moved his arm And he made contact with the third rail and just sparks flew up and down his body and I thought he was dead like I thought it was done But it didn't kill him and he looked up at me and he reached out his hand to me and I was like, ah, no, and I just grabbed his hand and helped pull him up out of the subway tracks. Jeremy experienced a bolt of electricity
shoot through him as he pulled the man up from the tracks. But he completed the rescue. A crowd that had gathered, cheered, someone recorded the entire incident. Very quickly, the story went viral. Jeremy was invited to go on television. Jeremy Clifton joins us right now live in the beautiful city of Atlanta, Georgia. Jeremy, who usually goes by chair, was lauded as a savior.
And the victim, he was characterized as a good for nothing drunk. Apparently he'd had way too much to drink earlier before he wound up at the subway. Jared didn't like the way the story was unfolding. He had helped someone who had fallen. He didn't feel he had done anything heroic. Yeah, I became increasingly uncomfortable with this story and I didn't like it at all. What actually made Jair unusual is that the incident prompted him to ask a question that was fundamentally psychological in nature. Why was his perception of the incident so different? This week on Hidden Brain, we explore this mystery of perception and the powerful implications
it has for living a harmonious and meaningful life. In 1982, Tara broke out in a small community in Lebanon just outside Beirut. A paramilitary group stormed the Palestinian refugee camp, killing hundreds. Almost immediately, they were speculated that the Israeli army, who had invaded Lebanon weeks before, had coordinated the attack. A few years later, the psychologist Lee Ross showed media coverage of the incident to two groups.
One was pro-Israeli, the other was pro-Palestinian. Ross wanted to know, how would two groups of people with very different beliefs react to the same media clips. In a 2019 interview with the Association for Psychological Science, he described what he found. The data were really quite remarkable. There were no overlapping cases. Everybody who labeled themselves as pro-Israeli saw that coverage as more anti-Israeli than anyone who saw the coverage and was anti-Israeli. It was no overlap in the data.
Pro-Israelis felt the new Sclips painted Israel in a bad light. Propalastinians said no. The clips were depicting Palestinians in a bad light. How could it be, Ross wondered, that people could watch the very same clips and come to wildly different conclusions? This is an example where it was a natural experiment. We didn't cleverly design the materials to make this happen. The materials were designed by CBS and NBC News,
who, if anything, wanted their coverage to be seen as fair and impartial. But this phenomenon was strong enough so that they didn't, and everybody not only saw the media as biased against them. They wanted to censored, thought it was be harmful to show, and would turn people against their just cause. It was almost as if the two groups had seen two different realities. Lee Ross eventually came up with a term for this phenomenon.
He called it the hostile media effect. People on opposite sides of a spectrum can both feel the media is biased against them. Ironically, the more media outlets attempt to be fair, the less likely they often are to be perceived as impartial by partisans and others who are deeply invested in a particular viewpoint. If I see the world as white and you see it as black and someone comes along and says, it's kind of gray, a mixture of black and white,
we're both going to be dissatisfied. So we make the startling prediction that both the left and the right are going to think that the media are biased against them. Leros, who died in 2021, conducted a number of other experiments to show how people with different viewpoints see fundamentally different worlds. who died in 2021 conducted a number of other experiments to show how people with different viewpoints see fundamentally different worlds. One of his most important contributions was to coin the term, the fundamental attribution era.
The truly fundamental attribution era is really the illusion of objectivity, that I have a sense that what I perceive is the way it really is. And that's just with the fact that as human beings we perceive a real world that has color and solid substances, and we take it for granted that our perception of things are as they really are. And therefore, to the extent that other people see it differently, the thing to be explained is why there was other people see it differently. This is why, when others don't agree with us on some important issue, we swiftly assume there must be something wrong with them.
They must be misinformed, uneducated, biased. These beliefs can cause international conflicts, but they also show up in our daily lives. As you see it in elderly couples arguing about how to set the thermostat, one says the room is too cold, and the other says no it's lovely. And one of them will agree to accommodate the other and from their viewpoint sit in a boiling hot room to accommodate their spouse, but they have no doubt that the room is actually boiling hot, and there's something wrong with their spouse. But great comic George Carlin had a line.
He said, did you ever notice? I've never noticed when you're driving that anyone who's driving slower than you is an idiot? And anyone driving faster than you is a maniac! Yours, after the subway incident in Atlanta, Jerric Lifton stumbled on the idea of the fundamental attribution era. He was starting to become a psychologist.
Lee Ross' work helped to make his own experience make sense. He had believed that the way he saw the world was objectively true. But what he saw was shaped by his prior beliefs, just like everybody else's version of reality, was shaped by their points of view. Jair realized he felt his behavior on the subway platform was not unusual because he tended to have an optimistic view about people. In fact, this had started right from when he was a child. So I grew up with a stutter and my full name is J. A. R. Me and I still get stuck on it.
I'm a pretty outgoing guy. I'm a pretty extroverted guy, and Stuttering made me more of a thinker, and I thought God gave me a stutter because he wanted me to write. In this optimistic view, Jair Stutter became a kind of superpower. He found ways to work around his stutter, like drawing out his speech. Over time, Jair came by the work of another pioneer in behavioral science. Psychologist Aaron Beck was not looking at geopolitical conflict. He was studying people with emotional disorders.
And Beck comes along and he was a depression researcher. And he found that depressed people were making these claims like, I'm worthless, or my boss hates me, or my spouse thinks that I'm not good at this, and so on and so forth. And people had known for forever that these extremely negative beliefs were a part of depression somehow, but they thought that they were symptoms. And Beck was really the first one who was like, you know what, these extremely simple
and even simplistic statements are not symptoms, perhaps. They are causes. It turned out to be a profound insight. Most of us think that we see the world as it is, that our beliefs are shaped by our experiences. So we don't stop to wonder if our beliefs might actually shape the world we see. So if you think that your boss doesn't like you or hates you and you get a ambiguous email from him. Your belief might be pushing you to believe something that might not be true. An ambiguous email from a supervisor can be interpreted as a passive-aggressive comment instead of a simple reminder of an upcoming deadline.
of an upcoming deadline. Aaron Beck hypothesized that if our beliefs about the world cause us to see the world in a negative light, changing those beliefs could change the way we experience the world. By deliberately re-appraising and recalibrating our thinking, we can change the way we feel. We can swap out the lens through which we see the world, for another lens, a better, more accurate lens. Eventually, this treatment approach became known
as cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT. There are a variety of tools that clinicians have to teach a person in a therapy session to dispute their belief and the interpretations of any given event in their life that the belief might influence. And to this day, it's arguably the most important inner mention that researchers have. And it's based on the idea that these beliefs are not symptoms, that they are causes of depression outcomes. Lee Ross had shown it was a mistake to assume that the way we see the world is the way it really is. Aaron Beck reinforced this idea by showing how false beliefs about our flaws and failings
can cause untold, disparent suffering. When we come back, Jair Clifton starts to ask, what are the other lenses that shape how we see the world? You'll listen to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Every day, everywhere in the world, people clash with other people. We struggle to understand why others don't quite see things our way,
from our loved ones to our world leaders. We ascribe our differences to personality quirks. My husband doesn't want to go wine tasting because he's unadventurous. Or we attribute our conflicts to differences in intellect. My uncle doesn't support the new proposition because he's uninformed. Sometimes we can't seem to pin our differences on anything at all. Someone disagrees with us and we wonder how could they possibly believe that? We shake our heads at their irrationality.
possibly believe that. We shake our heads at their irrationality. Psychological research suggests a different explanation. All of us assume we see the world objectively, when in fact we don't. Since everyone has a different version of reality inside their heads and everyone believes their version is objectively true, you end up with disagreement and conflict. At the University of Pennsylvania, Jared Clifton learned about the work of Lee Ross and Aaron Beck. He asked himself if there were fundamental beliefs that shaped the way large numbers of people perceive reality. He found a lot of research that examined one particular set of beliefs, whether people thought the world was fair or unfair and Believe in the just world is an idea from Melvin
Learner 1980 and this is the belief that the world is a place where you get what you deserve and deserve what you get And it has been tied to dozens and dozens and dozens of different life outcomes. And they really come down to four main buckets, right? So if you see the world as a just place, you tend to work hard. So belief in a just world is tied to GDP in countries. It's tied to being more productive in the workplace. And the idea is that if you work hard, you just have this assumption that it'll come back to you somehow. It's tied to be nicer, because don't be a jerk,
because that's going to come back and bite you. Be nice, because the world will reward you for that. So when you meet a stranger, like don't be a jerk. The third one is that you tend to be happier, because of course, it's nicer to be in a place that's just and also if you work hard and you're nicer you tend to be more successful. But the fourth bucket is you tend to blame victims. So not as good of a thing. So if the world is just placed then if you're poor then maybe you were lazy. If you're sick well maybe you didn't take precautions and so on and so forth. And so believing in the just world is even tied to like blaming sexual assault victims amongst women because the assumption is again that like well the world tends to be a place where you get what you deserve. So it's tied to both these good things and these bad things.
The voluminous research into just world beliefs showed Jair how beliefs could have profound downstream effects on behavior. And as with the Israelis and Palestinian supporters in Lee Ross's experiment or the depressed patients in Aaron Beck studies, people had no idea that their views about hard work or politeness or the criminal justice system were being influenced by the beliefs that they had brought to those questions. As Jair found more and more evidence that belief in a just world plays a powerful role in perception, he asked himself an important
question. When we discovered belief in a just world and that so much great work had been done already, we were like, well, that's just one of them, right? Like what about the other ones? What about the other ones? What other beliefs were out there that could have profound effects on the way we see reality, the way we act in the world. Jair recruited a team of researchers to identify as many general beliefs of the world as possible. They looked at religious texts and famous writings going back thousands of years. Oh my goodness, so this is what's, to me, pretty insane about these beliefs is that they've been in plain sight like for so long.
So in Ecclesiastes, all things are meaningless. That's a belief about the world that nothing matters. The duke, the first of the four, no-beltrude's aboo-dism is that life is suffering. A definitive aspect of life is suffering. Hera Klaitis thought the world was defined by change. She's the one that said you can't step into the same river twice. Pah, Thagares said that the world is defined by beauty. You can see global beliefs being expressed all the time in popular culture. Think of the classic line from Wesley, the main character in the movie The Princess Bright. You mock my pain. Life is pain, Highness. Anyone who says differently is selling something. Or the classic line from the movie Forrest Gump. My mom always said, life was like a box of chocolates.
You never know what you're going to get. Jair and his three-year-old kid recently watched Tangled. Disney's take on the classic fairy tale Rapunzel. I love this story because the whole thing is about your beliefs about the world as a whole is one big place. So the witch is trying to manipulate Rapunzel by teaching her that the world is a scary place, like that's what she says. And Rapunzel goes out into the world anyway, and at first she's scared, she jumps at like
the bunny in the bushes. Superfiance, folks, have they come for me? She goes to the bar with the scary looking people just to find out that they're actually nice, and things look scary and they're actually nice, a lot of the time. I've got a dream, see how I ain't just cruel and vicious as I see. And then she discovers throughout the film
such that the big moment when she realizes this world is wondrous and you were trying to manipulate me and it's a privilege to be alive in this world. Once Jair and his team began identifying these overarching beliefs about the world, that it's wondrous or that it's dangerous or that it's painful, they couldn't stop. They launched into a full-scale research project. So we spent 18 months trying to wrap our arms around, what are all of the possible beliefs that one could have about the world's whole as one big place. Really basic beliefs. So we look through 80,000 tweets
that begins with phrases like the world is, life is, and everything is. The universe is falling apart. The world is full of magical things. The universe is a scary place. We had 12 focus groups, ten of which were in the four biggest world religions. If God wills it.
Nothing is by chance. My home is with God. We looked at the 840 most used adjectives in contemporary American English drawn from a day to base of 450 million words. Present. Good. Boring. Abundant.
Mechanical. Peaceful. And that's like four or three of like ten things we did. After all this digging, Jair and his team reached something of a saturation point, meaning they weren't discovering any new beliefs. They grouped together varying perspectives that people had about the world. They called these perspectives primal world beliefs.
Jair said they fell into three main categories. The first one is a belief the world is a safe place versus a more dangerous place. Think back to the movie Tangled. Rapunzel saw the world through the witch's eyes as a scary place where everyone was out to get her. Over time, this belief changed. She began to see the world as a place that she could freely explore. The second main belief is the belief the world is enticing versus dull. And the central idea is to that one is the belief that the world is full of beautiful and interesting and meaningful and funny things versus dull, barren, boring, ugly. Maybe you had a roommate in college who found everything dull,
while you found yourself fascinated by the smallest things. It's likely you were on opposite ends of the enticing versus dull spectrum. The third main belief was that the world was alive, rather than mechanistic. And that's the belief that the world is imbued with intention and purpose that interacts with you and needs your help for an important task. And so the flip side of that is folks can see the world as mechanistic and that's the belief that the world has no special need of you, things don't occur because of some purpose,
and it isn't interacting with you in a special way, and it's probably indifferent. If you reflect on where you fall on the spectrum of each of these beliefs, you'll likely see that there are connections between them. So if you tend to see the world as safe, you also likely see the world as enticing. And you also likely compared to others tend to see the world as alive. In the same way, if you see the world as a dangerous place, the odds are that you see the world
as a dull place and a mecha-nistic place. These connections play into something Jair calls an umbrella belief, a belief at the top of the hierarchy that affects everything else. And that overarching idea is whether you believe the world is a good place or a bad place. This is perhaps the most fundamental question that all of us have to respond to, is this world worth existing? Is it a privilege to get to live in this world? Or is it more of a curse to have been born here?
And according to all of these incredible theorists and researchers, we have every reason to think this overarching belief that the world is a good place, as well as the other should play a role in a whole range of different life outcomes. Some of these outcomes are straightforward. For example, if you see the world as an enticing place, you are
probably a more curious person than someone who sees the world as dull. But what about the outcomes associated with believing the world is a fundamentally bad place where danger exists at every turn and people are mostly self-serving? Could holding this belief protect people from bad things? To answer this question, Jair's team studied the effect that seeing the world as a dangerous place had on people. They looked at parents and children. Many, many parents want to teach their kids that the world's a bad place. And that's not like a reflective act. It is a conscious goal that they have.
It seems intuitive that if kids learn the world is dangerous, they will be more vigilant about dangers. It makes sense that teaching them this belief could protect them from harm, but that's not what Jair and his team discovered. And basically we found very little evidence, very few places where seen the world as a bad place was tied to good things. Thinking about who are the people that tend to be successful, who are the people that tend to be healthy, they're not people who see the world as a dangerous place, they're
people who tend to see it as safe. Again, the lenses through which we see the world change the world that we see. As Aaron Beck had found with depressed patients, some lenses cause people to feel sadness and despair. Other lenses cause them to feel better adjusted. Most of us have views about whether the world is a good place or a bad place, a safe place or a dangerous place. But if you set aside for a moment the question of which beliefs you think people should have,
and ask instead which beliefs allow people to live more meaningful and harmonious lives, the question then becomes the same question Aaron Beckost. Is there a way to swap out lenses that make us unhappy for ones that make us feel and function better? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. You've heard the saying to see the world through roasted-inted glasses. The implication is that you put a positive spin on things. But why do some of us see the world with a rosy glow while others feel like we're looking through smudged and scratched spectacles.
And if you're a member of that second group, is it possible to swap out your lenses for new ones? At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Jerric Lifton has encountered two similar stories with very different endings that help to answer this question. The first is about Jer's grandfather-in-law, who was a combat dentist in World War II. He walked on the front lines, helping peace back together the faces and mouths of soldiers. It was a brutal job. After returning from war, he struggled to see the world as anything but cruel.
And thus, a family saying was born. Whenever something bad happened, he turned to a son, Jair's father-in-law, and say, Life's a s**t sandwich and you just took your first bite. And this became like a mantra. And it was shared in a loving way. It was like, hey, I need to teach you this really important thing about the world. The world's going to be a bad place and you need to be prepared for it. This story stood out to Jair as a prime example of how experiences can shape your beliefs about the world. That was until Jair thought back on an experience he had had in college.
He was in Europe on a choir trip when he met an older tour guide named Sarah. She was one of those cool people that everyone in the group was trying to figure out how they could talk to her. So I got my time with her in the basement of a restaurant in Lithu way, where it was like exposed brick. It's where they keep the wine. The candles are melting off of the side of the brick. She told me the story of being a young Jewish girl in Poland,
where at the very beginning of World War II, the Nazis and the Russians split Poland in half and take it. And the Nazis came through her town and marched people down both sides of a street, and then the Nazis in the middle of the street turned and shot all the people on one side. And then they turned to the other side, and that was Sarah and her mom and dad and her sister, I think, and shipped them off to Concentre, Jean-Campson. She went to Four Camps, and I can't remember the name of the first three, but the last one was Auschwitz. And at that point, I believe her parents
and her sister had already died. And she was in Auschwitz, Christmas Eve 1944. So this is the last Christmas of the war. And she doesn't know that. She's just been in these camps now for years. In the biggest perhaps worst camp of the war, Christmassy, and she was sick. So she was in the in Fur Marie. So like the worst part of the worst camp, like incredibly awful conditions. And she was lying there in a cot, and there was a girl next to her about the same age.
And they reached across the cot, and they held hands. And she said to me in this basement of this restaurant, and that's realized that the world was so full of love and connection, and it was massive and impossible to stamp out. And the world was so wondrous, so wondrous that I had no choice but to believe that there was a God and to be grateful. So, I mean, you give me two examples of people. One, your grandfather in law, who, as you said, was a combat dentist in World War II, and Sarah's in a concentration camp also in World War II, and they both go through terrible experiences. And one of them basically says, you know, life is terrible, and welcome to this terrible world that's only going to get
worse with time. And the other one says, life is wondrous and amazing and we're filled and surrounded by connection and love. It begs the question, where do these beliefs come from? Because clearly both Sarah and your grandfather and law had ample evidence to support the belief that the world is in fact unsafe. One of them did and one of them didn't. Exactly. Like the funny thing is, is that we all tell these tales of our lives to make sense of our beliefs. But for all I know that my granddad and law already saw the world as a bad place.
And the experience that he went through just confirmed that the world is a bad place. And Sarah might have already seen the world as a good place, but that moment might have even pushed her more, like it might have crystallized for her. So it's entirely possible that they each approached the incredibly awful things that they came through and were essentially strengthened in the beliefs that they already had. And don't leave.
Jair was seeing that people did not always arrive at their primal beliefs as a result of their experiences. But he wanted to test this idea scientifically. He and his colleagues put together a survey asking lay people and researchers to guess what people's primal world beliefs were after giving them information about people's backgrounds. Do you think people who live in high crimes of codes would see the world as a dangerous place? And to what extent? Do you think people who are rich see the world as abundant?
They also asked, do you think people who are poor see the world as more barren? Do you think people who have experienced trauma perceive the world as more dangerous? Then they look to see how people's predictions lined up with reality. Do people in high crime zip code see the world is more scary? Do people in high income zip code see the world is more abundant? Do people who are wealthy see the world is more abundant? And so on and so forth. And I think what's kind of surprising is that people who are rich aren't more likely to see the world as abundant.
People who are poor aren't more likely to see the world as barren. People who live in high-crime zip codes aren't more likely to see the world as a dangerous place. And of course, that's really different than like a rich, incredible, leabat experience like being a combat dentist in World War II or going through Auschwitz.
So like, I'm very reluctant to make claims on the impact of extreme particular traumas. But I think what we're finding just again and again and again and again is that human beings are actually terrible at predicting the primal world beliefs of people based on their backgrounds. Our beliefs do not appear to be the consequence of our experiences. Instead, as Aaron back hypothesized, they are the lenses through which we see everything that happens to us. Take, for instance, the COVID-19 pandemic.
Pandemics are awful, but if you study world beliefs, worldwide events are very useful. And it was fascinating because we assumed that when the world objectively became a more dangerous place, that the belief the world as a dangerous place would go up. And we had two samples that we administered right before the pandemic, it was just luck that we had these samples, both in the U.S. And what we found was no change at all. No change at all. There was no statistically detectable change in these samples in their belief that the world is a dangerous place because of the pandemic. Jerk Lifton realized that if primal beliefs are upstream of our experiences rather than the consequence of
our experiences, we can and probably should change our beliefs in ways that can make our lives more meaningful. If people aren't updating these beliefs because of worldwide events, and if people aren't updating these beliefs because of the events in your own lives, then if you wanna see the world as a good place, if that's like an attractive option to you,
根据我们的经验，我们可以也或许应该改变我们的信念，以此让生活更有意义。如果人们不因为世界上的事件而更新这些信念，如果人们不因为你生活中的事件而更新这些信念，那么如果你想把世界看作一个美好的地方，如果这对你来说是一个具有吸引力的选择，
there is no reason to wait. There is no reason to wait until your own life gets better or the world gets better. Because the odds are, if it does get better, if it got dramatically better, the odds are, is that your primals would not change. Jair has personal experience with changing one of his own primal beliefs. When he was in college, he began to feel like life was dull. So he did something about it. He took active measures to cultivate his own curiosity
那就没有理由等待。没有必要等到你自己的生活变好或者世界变好。因为很有可能的是，即使它真的变好了，即使它发生了戏剧性的好转，你的本源世界观也不会改变。杰尔（Jair）有改变自己某个本源信念的亲身经历。上大学时，他开始觉得生活很枯燥。于是他采取了行动。他积极采取措施培养自己对自然界的好奇心。
about the natural world. And one of the things that I did in my own life that seemed to change my belief was called the leaf exercise. So the leaf exercise is an exercise where I'm trying to reintroduce the fact that ubiquitous beauty is all around us all the time. That beauty that we ignore, that we don't pay attention to is there, and we just don't see it. So in this exercise, you go to a park or a forest, you pluck a single leaf off of a tree and you look at that one leaf.
而在我自己的生活中，有一件事似乎改变了我的信念，那就是叶子练习。叶子练习是一种这样的练习：我试图重新认识这样一个事实，即无处不在的美随时随地环绕着我们。那些我们忽视的、没有去注意的美其实一直都在，只是我们没有看见。所以在这种练习中，你去公园或森林，从树上摘下一片叶子，然后端详这片叶子。
And you look at the speckled nest on the front and the veins on the back and you soak up the beauty in that single leaf. You pluck a second leaf from the tree. You look at that leaf. You look at how the story of that leaf is similar but not the same as the one you just plucked. Then you take a step back and take a deep breath and you look at the tree. The average adult oak tree has 250,000 leaves. Each one is a beautiful thing. And then you take a proverbial step back and I would take a
你看着正面的斑点和背面的叶脉，沉浸在那片单薄叶子的美之中。你从树上摘下第二片叶子。你看着那片叶子。你观察这片叶子的故事与你刚摘的那片有哪些相似却又不同之处。然后你退后一步，深吸一口气，看着这棵树。一棵普通成年橡树有25,000片叶子。每一片都是美丽的艺术品。然后你退一步，在脑海中退后一步，
step back in my mind and just imagine the four risks of Siberia and the Amazon and then you take another step back of all these leaves and you think about all of the plants and the trees that have gone before you that produce the air that you now breathe and all of the trees that will come because you just have a slice in time you just have the leaves that exist right now all the air that you now breathe and all of the trees that will come. Because you just have a slice in time, you just have the leaves that exist right now, all the leaves that will come. And then you pile all those leaves and you realize that all these leaves, if they were rare, would be mounted in place in halls of art. And it's only that they're ubiquitous, that they fall and we walk on them, and they're considered worthless. And then you ask yourself what sort of world this is.
想象一下西伯利亚和亚马逊的四大风险，然后你再退一步，看着所有这些叶子，思考着在你之前所有产生你现在呼吸的空气的植物和树木，以及未来将要出现的所有的树木，因为你只占据了时间的一个切片，你只拥有此时此刻存在的叶子，所有你现在呼吸的空气和未来将要出现的树木。因为你只占据了时间的一个切片，你只拥有此时此刻存在的叶子，所有将要出现的叶子。然后你把所有的叶子堆叠起来，你会意识到，如果所有这些叶子很稀有，它们就会被镶嵌在艺术殿堂里。正因为它们无处不在，掉落在地上被我们踩踏，它们才被认为毫无价值。然后你就会问自己，这到底是一个什么样的世界。
And what's your thinking that this will do for you? The disability to slow down, see the world in its wondrousness? What do you hope that it's going to accomplish for you? Well, so I did that exercise like maybe once a week or so. And I also started to journal about five new beautiful things that I saw each day. And for me, I really, the central idea for me in my own life was the belief that the world is a beautiful place. It felt awkward at first.
你觉得这样做对你有什么用？那种能够放慢脚步、用惊叹的眼光看待世界的能力？你希望这能为你带来什么？嗯，我大概每周左右做一次这个练习。我还开始写日记，记录我每天看到的五个美丽的新事物。对我来说，我生活中最核心的理念就是“世界是一个美好的地方”这个信念。一开始觉得很不习惯。
It felt like I wasn't good at it. And then I got better at it, like the muscle developed. And I began to just pour out, and I would, and I found myself just walking around noticing beautiful things in my life and it's partly why I fell in love with my wife because she would point out the beautiful things in my life and we became buddies to like see the beauty that is around us all the time.
感觉自己很不擅长。后来我做得越来越好，就像肌肉得到了锻炼。我开始倾注热情，我发现自己开始四处走动，注意到生活中的美好事物，这也是我爱上我妻子的部分原因，因为她会指出我生活中的美好事物，我们成了寻找时刻环绕着我们的美的伙伴。
And I realized from that process that my own well-being was going up. This is not to say that changing primal beliefs is easy or quick. Very much as Aaron Beck found with cognitive behavioral therapy, changing the way you think involves practice and effort. The habits of mind that you have cultivated over 20, 40 or 60 years cannot be changed overnight. As Jair showed with his research on the effects of the COVID pandemic, primal beliefs are not easily shaken. Just because beliefs are stable across time doesn't mean that they can't be changed, but we're not going to change them just by making our own lives
我从这个过程中意识到，我自身的幸福感在上升。这并不是说改变本源信念是容易或迅速的。正如亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）通过认知行为疗法所发现的那样，改变思维方式需要实践和努力。你在20、40或60年里培养出来的思维习惯是不可能在一夜之间改变的。正如杰尔关于新冠大流行影响的研究所示，本源信念是不那么容易动摇的。信念在时间上保持稳定，并不意味着它们不能被改变，但我们不会仅仅通过让自己的生活
or the world better. And I think that's the big takeaway, that the world might get dramatically better. Your own life might get dramatically better. And that's probably not going to change. Your world believes that much. Efforts to change your world beliefs have to be about something else. And I think that comes down to understanding that there are lenses by exploring the fact that you have a lens, that you don't have to have the lens that you have, that there are options. The nice thing is now, Shankar, is that you got people that are way more smart than me who are working on this now. There's a whole bunch of incredible research coming.
或世界变得更好来改变它们。我想这才是最核心的结论：世界可能会发生翻天覆地的变化。你自己的生活可能会变得好得多。但那可能并不会改变你的世界观。改变你的世界观的努力必须关乎其他方面。我认为这归结为理解存在着不同的视角，通过探索这样一个事实：你拥有某种视角，你不一定非得局限于现有的视角，你还有其他的选择。好消息是，尚卡尔（Shankar），现在有比我聪明得多的人正在研究这个。有大量不可思议的研究正在进行。
In the next few years, I'm very hopeful that someone's going to begin to crack the code about how not just to shift these beliefs, but to change them quite a bit. The research on how to change primal world beliefs is ongoing. Jair, as you might expect from a person who is an optimist, is optimistic. But even if you don't change your beliefs, Jair argues there are important reasons just to understand the primal beliefs you do have. He discovered this himself in his interactions with his mother. So I have a history of living in rough parts of town.
在接下来的几年里，我非常希望有人能够开始破解密码，不仅是如何转变这些信念，而且是如何在很大程度上改变它们。关于如何改变本源世界观的研究仍在继续。正如你对一个乐观主义者的期望一样，杰尔是乐观的。但即使你不改变你的信念，杰尔认为，仅仅去理解你所拥有的本源信念，也有着重要的原因。他在与母亲的互动中亲身体会到了这一点。我有一段在治安较差的地区生活的经历。
So my wife and I have lived in West Philly. We lived in the west side of Buffalo. And my mom has lived in Taiwan and Hong Kong and has lived in all these parts of the world. And when she would come to visit me, she would be anxious. She would make comments about the crime where I lived. And she just kind of like was negative about where I lived. What would you say? It was nothing dramatic. It was just like, oh man, I've heard that crime is really going up here. And like, do you think that like, it's okay that I park here?
我和我妻子曾住在费城西部。我们住在布法罗的西区。我妈妈曾在台湾和香港生活过，在世界各地许多地方生活过。当她来探望我时，她会感到焦虑。她会对我居住地方的治安评头论足。她对我的居住环境有点负面看法。你会怎么说？那没什么夸张的。就好像是，天哪，我听说这里的犯罪率真的在上升。你觉得把车停在这里安全吗？
And it was just like a constant like negative stream of like, man, I wish you didn't live in such a rough area. And I kind of got to the point that I just kind of felt vaguely insulted, like it was a predictable thing that like she would come and I would feel vaguely insulted about where I live. And it annoyed me. When Jerp began researching primal world beliefs, he developed a survey that would identify people's world beliefs depending on their answers. He sent it to a bunch of folks in his life, including his mom.
这就像是一种源源不断的负面言论，比如，天哪，我真希望你不住在这么乱的地区。我甚至有点觉得被冒犯了，就好像她来这里然后我对自己的居住地感到有些被冒犯成了一种惯例。这让我很恼火。当杰尔开始研究本源世界观时，他开发了一项调查，可以根据人们的回答来识别他们的世界观。他把它发给了他生活中的许多人，包括他的妈妈。
So she took the survey and she sent me the results. Turns out my own mother sees the world as a dangerous place. And I looked at it and I thought there was a mistake, because my mom is outgoing. She's not anxious. We had people in our lives all the time, she kicked my butt out the door and said, yes, you have a stutter but go have fun and explore and don't be scared. And when I discovered this like last year, it kind of blew my mind and it
于是她做了调查，并把结果发给了我。原来我自己的母亲把世界看作一个危险的地方。我看了看，以为是弄错了，因为我妈妈很外向。她并不焦虑。我们生活中总是有人做客，她把我赶出家门说：“没错，你有点口吃，但去玩去探索吧，不要害怕。”当我去年发现这一点时，我的脑洞大开，它
allowed me to understand all these stories from my past in like a new way. stories from my past in like a new way. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in that we use these beliefs to fill in ambiguity in our lives when we don't know. And so my mom would come to visit me in these new places. She would fill in based on her general belief about the world as a whole. But then as she learned more about that place, she would need to rely less on this prior belief. And then it would go away.
让我以一种全新的方式理解了过去的种种故事。我们用这些信念来填补生活中我们未知时的模糊空白。所以每当我妈妈来这些新地方看望我时。她就会根据她对整个世界的整体信念来进行填补。但后来随着她对那个地方了解更多，她对这种先验信念的依赖就会减少。然后这种感觉就会消失。
And it wasn't because my mom was anxious or fearful or whatever, it's because she had this underlying belief about the world. And to me, that's like a really important takeaway. We're working on different ways to change these beliefs and which ones are helpful and which ones are hurtful and so on and so forth, but at minimum, it allows us to understand each other. I'm less angry at my mother when she's comes to visit me and she's scared or anxious about the part of town
这并不是因为我妈妈焦虑、恐惧或者别的什么，而是因为她对世界有着这种潜在的信念。对我来说，这是一个非常重要的收获。我们正在研究改变这些信念的不同方法，哪些是有益的，哪些是有害的，等等，但至少，这让我们能够互相理解。当她来探望我、对我的居住区感到害怕或焦虑时，
that I live in. I've come to expect that and be patient with that because if I, if we switched our beliefs, if I had her belief about the world, I would likely be doing the exact same thing. If you consider your own life, it's likely you sometimes lock horns with the people around you. It might be an overbearing parent or a coworker, or maybe it's a friend who doesn't seem to share your political views.
我对母亲的愤怒减少了。我已经习惯了这一点，并对此保持耐心，因为如果我和她互换信念，如果我对世界有她那样的看法，我很有可能会做出完全相同的举动。如果你想想自己的生活，你很可能有时会与周围的人发生冲突。那可能是一个专横的父母或同事，或者可能是一个似乎与你的政治观点不一致的朋友。
Jared says taking a moment to consider that primal world beliefs might be a game changer. I'm guessing there's a whole bunch of people that are extremely close to you that you might actually not know their underlying beliefs about the world as a whole, and if you knew them, it would provide insight and more patience as you deal with them. knew them, it would provide insight and more patience as you deal with them. That's actually a huge way that I've become a lot more patient is deeply understanding the primal world-lace of each side. It's allowed me to become more patient with the people in my life. Jeremy Clifton is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura
杰尔说，花点时间思考一下本源世界观可能会改变游戏规则。我猜有很多人与你非常亲密，但你其实并不了解他们对整个世界的潜在信念，如果你了解了，它会在你与他们打交道时提供深刻的见解和更多的耐心。这实际上是我变得更有耐心的一种巨大方式，那就是深入理解双方的本源世界观。这让我对生活中的人更有耐心。杰里米·克利夫顿（Jeremy Clifton）是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉
Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. For today's Anson Hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. It's a story from our show My Anson Hero. Today's story comes from Kate Baker. About 20 years ago, Kate and her husband and their two-year-old son, Niel, were on a flight from New York to Europe. All three of us were healthy, but halfway over the Atlantic Ocean, Niel started to get very warm and his face was red. Then he started foaming at the mouth. He was
夸雷尔（Quarelle）、莱恩·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。对于今天的“安森英雄”环节，我们将话筒交给我们节目的听众。这是一个来自我们节目“我的安森英雄”的故事。今天的故事来自凯特·巴克（Kate Baker）。大约20年前，凯特和她的丈夫以及他们两岁的儿子尼尔（Niel）乘坐从纽约飞往欧洲的航班。我们三个人都很健康，但在飞越大西洋的中途，尼尔开始发烧，脸变得通红。接着他开始口吐白沫。他
having a seizure. The flight attendants were going up and down the aisle, asking anyone if they were a doctor, if they could take a look at him, no one would come forward, and then the pilot started announcing, is there a doctor on board? And should I turn this plane around, and again, no one came forward. Then one of the flight attendants asked my husband who was holding the ill, is he breathing? And he said just barely. I was standing in the aisle. Well when I heard those words, I think I must have gone into shock because I couldn't feel anything and I couldn't speak. Then I noticed three women passengers get out of their seats and come toward me. They were Muslim women wearing the hijab and they came to me and
癫痫发作了。乘务员在过道里走来走去，询问任何人是否是医生，是否能照看一下他，没有人站出来，然后机长开始广播：“机上有医生吗？我需要把飞机调头吗？”同样，没有人站出来。接着，一位乘务员问抱着生病孩子的我丈夫：“他在呼吸吗？”他说：“微弱得很。”我正站在过道里。当我听到这些话时，我想我一定是休克了，因为我什么也感觉不到，也说不出话来。然后我注意到三名女乘客从座位上站起来向我走来。她们是戴着头巾的穆斯林女性，她们走到我身边，
put their arms around me. Then they were speaking to me in a language that I didn't understand. It might have been Arabic or Turkish. I'm not sure. But the tone of their voice was so so soothing and they stood there with me with their arms around me until the flight attendant told us that we should move to the front of the plane and take a seat up there. We arrived in Amsterdam and went directly to the clinic. They couldn't find anything wrong with Neil. By that time he was fine, but we got on another plane in a few hours and went back home to New Jersey. We went immediately to a pediatrician who discovered that Neil had just had an ear infection. And he had a seizure because his temperature spiked very rapidly on the plane.
把手臂搂在我身上。然后她们用一种我听不懂的语言对我说着什么。可能是阿拉伯语，也可能是土耳其语。我不确定。但她们的语调是如此地舒缓，她们一直站在我身边，用手臂搂着我，直到乘务员告诉我们应该移到飞机前部并在那里找个座位坐下。我们抵达阿姆斯特丹后直接去了诊所。他们没有发现尼尔有任何问题。当时他已经没事了，但我们在几个小时后登上了另一架飞机，回到了新泽西的家。我们立即去找儿科医生，医生发现尼尔只是得了耳部感染。由于他在飞机上的体温急剧飙升，他才引发了癫痫发作。
So Neil was fine, we treated him for the ear infection, and everything was fine. But I never forgot those women and how supportive they were. I grew up in a place where there were no Muslims, very few people of color, and everyone spoke English. So that encounter was very new for me. I will never forget them and what they did for me. We may not speak the same language or share the same beliefs or religion, but none of that really matters to me because we can connect on a very deep human level. So if I ever saw those women again, I would just say thank you so much and I love you. Kate Baker lives in Middlesex, New Jersey.
所以尼尔没事了，我们治疗了他的耳部感染，一切都很好。但我永远不会忘记那些女性以及她们给予我的支持。我成长的地方没有穆斯林，几乎没有有色人种，每个人都说英语。所以那次相遇对当时的我是个全新的体验。我永远不会忘记她们以及她们为我做的事。我们可能语言不通，也没有相同的信仰或宗教，但这些对我来说其实并不重要，因为我们可以在非常深厚的人性层面上产生连接。所以如果我再次见到那些女性，我只想说：“非常感谢你们，我爱你们。”凯特·巴克住在新泽西州米德尔塞克斯。
Her son Neil is now grown and works with adults who have autism. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and join the hundreds of other hidden brain listeners who have agreed to help. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedanthanam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她的儿子尼尔现在已经长大成人，并从事与自闭症成年人相关的工作。如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的故事，请立即行动。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org，加入其他几百位同意提供帮助的“隐藏的大脑”听众的行列。再次强调，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦达坦瑟姆（Shankar Vedantam）。再见。这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。